Hey, David, do you believe that the number
of seats in the House of Representatives should
be expanded?
This came up on a recent youtube livestream
that I did.
Uh, and my answer is basically, yes, I do.
Right now each house seat represents about
750,000 people.
And uh, there have been 435 seats in the House
of Representatives dating all the way back
to the late twenties, I believe.
1929 and obviously the population of the United
States has grown hugely.
I think it's almost three times bigger today
than it was back in 1929 maybe even more.
I'm now just going by rough numbers, but the,
the point is each congressional district used
to, uh, include way fewer people than it does
today.
And if we wanted to keep the same proportional
representation that we had in 1929 today,
we should grow the house of Representatives
to somewhere between 1100 and 1200 members.
Okay.
We have four 35.
And what you have to understand when you think
about this issue is that this runs directly
counter to the interests of those who are
already in the House of Representatives.
What I mean by that is if you got elected
to the House of Representatives and you currently
represent 750,000 people and you are one out
of 435, why would you want to see your power
diminished by expanding the number of seats
in the House of Representatives?
Because what you would effectively be doing
is you would reduce the number of people that
you represent by reducing the number of people
in each congressional district and you would
be voting to make yourself not one out of
100 and a one out of 435 you make yourself
one out of a thousand or one out of 1200 and
most of the elected officials aren't going
to want to reduce their own power.
It's just not something most people want to
do.
It's similar to campaign finance reform, and
I've talked about this before, when we ask
our elected officials to change the campaign
finance system.
Yes, some of them say, I want to do it and
I would vote for it and I'll do it and I guess
we believe them when they say that, but if
you were elected to begin with with a particular
campaign finance system, many of those people
are not going to want to take apart the system
that got them elected to begin with.
Now, there are people who are thinking this
through a little bit more critically and they
realize that if we change the entire system,
everybody benefits and maybe their party actually
benefits more, I would argue that Democrats
would benefit more from reforms to the campaign
finance system than Republicans.
Uh, and that's when you can actually get some
sort of partisan agreement.
Right.
The reason that you would see significant
support for expanding the number of seats
in the House of Representatives would be if
one party determines that it would be good
for them.
I believe that it would be better for Democrats.
Democrats would benefit more.
When you expand the number of seats, you shrink
the advantage of the Electoral College for
Republicans currently that favors Republicans.
Um, and there are other sort of more micro
ways that I believe it would benefit Democrats.
Uh, but to make a long story short, yes, we
absolutely should expand the number of seats
in the House of Representatives.
Good luck doing it.
Uh, significant opposition would be seen.
Um, definitely from Republicans, maybe even
from centrist Democrats as well.
So I don't know that I see it happening anytime
soon, although I would love it.
If you disagree with me, let me know.
I want to know why.
Why should we not expand the number of seats
in the House of Representatives?
It used to expand with population and it is
not since 1929 what's so special.
Perfect.
How about four 35 we've got a great bonus
show for you today.
Become a member or a patient to get instant
access to the bone,